hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to a github tutorial so this is
gonna be a two-parter the first part
which is this video is gonna cover how
to actually use the website and just to
get the code as text kind of so just
using the website alone and then the
second video which is going to come out
tomorrow that's gonna cover how to
integrate it with eclipse because it
integrates really well with eclipse okay
so anyway this is by the way context of
this is for the Cherno chat which is the
network chat programming series so
that's like the example what we're gonna
use but of course you can use this for
any github project okay sorry the first
thing you need to do is actually go to a
URL and again that'll be in the
description and it is in the description
of every video in the network chat
programming series and that is the
repository right but before I show you
that I'm going to show you my account
basically so all we have to do is go to
github.com slash to china and that's it
and that'll come up with this and from
here this is gonna be basically all of
my all of my different code repositories
inside of that so the thing is I don't
actually have an hour - probably do that
but from here you can actually if you do
actually have a github account you can
follow me for example and you'll be able
to see any code that I personal last off
that's probably a good idea and of
course the main thing is you can you can
actually see all of my repositories
right here so I'm trying to turn oh sure
that's the only one I've got right now
so if we click on that and again that
takes us to github.com for slash to turn
off or turn on chat okay and that's the
link that is at the end of every network
chat programming video and so from here
what you can do is you can actually
really read me which is you know quite a
good read as you can see and but the
important thing is this is where the
code is actually located for Cherno chat
okay so if you look over here this this
is the list of files so if we hit sauce
comm showing and you can probably tell
that this is like the java packages how
they work we get to this file eventually
called login java and if we click that
you can actually see that we have
episode 3 here the episode 3 source code
which is right over here and the reason
we have episode 3 source code right now
is because that is the latest episode at
the time of me making this video I
haven't actually um I haven't ever
actually committed any other code
changes after that yet so that is all
the code as you
so you can read it here and everything's
nice you can actually copy it into
whatever you want with it but that's all
that's all good right and you can copy
it in everything in fact in fact if you
actually hit raw here you actually get a
much nicer looking interface as you can
see here and you can just command a or
control a whatever ctrl-c and ctrl-v
copy that to wherever you like and then
you'll just get the entire source code
that's good
but let's just say that um you know
you're not up to the latest episode and
you don't want to just copy all the code
from the latest episode you actually
want to copy let's just say you have two
Episode one something went wrong it's
not working you don't want to have to
deal with all this complex stuff it's
not that complex yet but it will be you
don't have to deal with all this you
just want to just get the bare
necessities down and just make sure that
it actually works for episode 1 you can
do that okay so let's go back to Cherno
chat you can say up here we've got four
commits and that's what it's at at the
moment okay all you have to do is click
on that for commits right here and that
will actually list all of the commits
and what our commits can message is
basically every time that I've pushed
new code onto this repository right so
every time I've added some changes and
I've decided to accept I guess the
changes I can actually add them into
this repository and that's what a commit
is so every time that I've actually
added code into this code base
that's called a commit and you can see
I've done it four times right now the
first one is just an initial commit and
that's just adding the read means
setting everything up but over here you
see episode 1 2 & 3 okay now let's just
say we're up to episode 1 because that
was our example you just simply click on
that and you'll see a list of all the
changes and it for this right now you'll
see a bunch of green here which means
that I've added code you can see that
I've got 37 I've changed one file with
37 edgy additions and 0 deletions and
from then on you can actually hit the
you can copy this but you can see
there's all these pluses here and it's
just not really nice you can hit the
view file button right over here and
then the role button and then just copy
it and you can see that this is much
less code than before because this is
only episode 1 code and then from then
on you know you can paste it into you
know sublime text or whatever your
favorite thing is eclipse of course
anything basically and you can see that
it all shows up nicely here and that's
just the code for episode 1 so that's
how that kind of works and using this
method of course you can access any
episode you want so let's just look at
episode 2 for example right over here
you can see over here that we actually
have a bunch of red here as well NASA
stuff that I've removed such as the
border layout important to set bounce
and you can see a diver remove set
bowels and added says lies and set
location relative to so you would have
seen that if you watched episode 2 and
yeah just in general you can see
everything that I've added and you can
actually see 18 conditions and for
deletions and all that stuff okay so
that's all cool and cool now let's take
let's take a look at what we can
actually do if we actually log in so hit
the sign up button if you don't already
have a github account if you do hit the
Sign In button I'm going to sign in as a
different account I'm going to sign in
as the channel project which is not the
account that has access to this
repository
I actually know my password is it
nothing is this yes sweet okay so I
don't have any verified emails great but
the point is now that we've logged in I
do not have access to this repository so
in other words I can't actually um add
changes to it this isn't the account
that I use to create this so this is
what your your view will kind of look
like what you can do from here is
there's actually a little watch thing
and a cool thing about watch thing is
I'll show you guys in a minute here but
there are these things on github called
discussions which are very cool as well
but if you hit the watching button
you'll actually be watch you'll actually
be watching for any changes here so
you'll get notified if I if I had a new
card but the cool thing is that you can
actually again let's just go to commit
here my steps are to UM and over here
right I've tried to set bounds and I've
added all this then you can actually
just hit this button right here so if
you hover your mouse over the line of
code and then hit the plus button thing
you can actually just write a write a um
comment to that specific line so for
example if you're getting an error at a
particular layer I use one make a
comment oh you think one line of code
might be done a better way you can be
like nice job churner that was sweet
and then you can just comment okay and
as you can say just love to comment on
that line and of course if you just want
to comment on the entire file you can do
that below as well okay so that's a
really cool thing that you can do it
again everyone will get um I think you
will get 100% sure but I think you'll
get a notification if you're involved in
it in a discussion and you add something
in blah blah blah you can mute it as you
can see here if you don't want to for
cash ins but um I think everyone
probably gonna get the certification
sweet github tutorial here okay and you
know etc I'm just showing you guys an
example and you can comment here you
guys can start discussions and all that
stuff that's that's what you can do if
you actually log in and that's what I
recommend you do created an account and
you follow this repository whatever you
want so yeah that's basically how you
can use github to a few code and talk
about it and sort of that it's a very
cool system it's very hard to set up
with an actual you know if you actually
want to add code to repository or remove
code from repositories that's kind of
hard but in order to actually integrate
this code into eclipse like instantly
I'm gonna show you guys how to do that
tomorrow so yes I'll see you guys then
good bye
you